hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i
am a property investor
and i am also a youtuber i do a youtube
video
every single day i post a lot of content
i do training programs i have instagram
tick tock and i spent a lot of time
putting videos out there online and
teaching people about property for free
i do have some uh paid training as well
and people always ask me samuel
we get it you do property you make a lot
of money in property but how much money
do you get paid from youtube and how
much money did you get paid from being
an influencer
and all that kind of stuff so i'm going
to answer that question in this video
i'm going to show you exactly how much
money youtube pay me which is my biggest
platform on social media
to do these videos now before i tell you
how much youtube pay me i just want to
say this firstly
i never started doing youtube videos
around property
until first i was financially free in
property my first ever youtube video
was actually 10 years ago and it was a
little vlog that i did
of myself in india i was in punjab
lydiana and i was out
on a mission trip doing charity work uh
working in orphanages i just did a
little vlog and posted it on youtube
and the reason i did that video was
because my church
asked me when i got back from the trip
they said we want to see some video
footage you want to see what you've been
up to
so i made this video to then tell the
story and show people in my church what
i was up to
i did a couple other videos on youtube i
did uh some
songs that i made i posted them on
youtube many years ago
and around about five years ago was when
i started posting videos around
property investing and it was more more
than like a how-to video like these are
the three ways to buy houses
it was more like vlog kind of style and
the reason i started youtube was because
i just wanted to show
my friends my family my church my
business connections my customers
kind of what i was up to what my
business was about it wasn't i didn't
intend on being a
youtuber now let's fast forward some
years
now 29 years old now doing a youtube
video every single day
the reason i do the youtube videos is
more for impact
it's for significance rather than for
the actual
money my training company that i have
which i guess is kind of
indirectly off the back of my social
media
my training business i don't make any
money personally
from my training business at all in fact
my training company
at one time it was profitable it was
quite profitable uh when it first
started taking off but then when we
employed staff and our overheads went up
my training company right now is not
particularly profitable
and to be honest i don't think it ever
will be when you look at the most
successful training companies in the
world
um there's not that much money in
training i don't think and you and
you're looking
somebody who's done a lot of training i
really do training for the enjoyment i
don't take a salary
from the training company i don't take a
salary from youtube
i don't get paid any money at the moment
from tick tock
instagram youtube is the only platform
that pays me money and i'm going to show
you exactly how much money youtube pays
me right now
so this is my youtube account and this
is what everybody can see when they go
onto my youtube you can see i have 171
000 subscribers
you can check out my videos these are
all my latest videos
uh however dun dun dun this
youtube studio is what the average
people cannot see
this is secret for samuel leeds eyes
only which i'm going to give you an
insight to so you can see
all the metrics so i mean i can see kind
of how many views i generally have
but let me go into analytics and i'm
going to get don't worry i'm going to
get to the payment i'm going to get to
the monetization
okay my estimated revenue in the last 28
days
is 47 pounds 19 pence however that is
only estimated
and i'm going to give you the full exact
figures
over the lifetime of my youtube channel
um you see the views i've had
418 000 views in the last 28 days that
is
less than usual it says 22 000 less than
usual
it says that typically i get between 441
583
it's about half a million views on
average per month which is okay
i guess i've had one and a half thousand
new subscribers
you can see it goes up and then it goes
down maybe that's when i say something
controversial but whatever
uh it doesn't matter because i only only
made 47 quid anyway
um yeah so this is my youtube channel
um engagement i can show you my audience
and stuff as well
um so my average audience
member so that's you the viewer let's
see who you are
so most of them are male 83 male 16
female
and the average age is between 25 and 34
just followed by 35 to 44 uh 22 and then
19
18 24. so the average age is probably
around about 29 years old which is the
same as me which is no surprise
um so yeah i mean i do get more people
that are
um 65 plus than 13 to 17 year olds so
you know i get very actually very few
teenagers which is crazy because i do
get teenagers commenting sometimes but
hey there's more pensioners than there
are teenagers that watch me on youtube
statistically more than double would you
look at that um most people from the uk
followed by the united states australia
canada ireland um
awesome thank you very much to my to my
non-uk
fans and and and watchers um so let's go
on to the this is the bit
monetization okay let's have a look
so step one review partner program terms
done step two i've been reviewed but
step two set up google adsense now
adsense
you know when you're watching a youtube
video and you see those
ads that pop up you don't usually see
them on my channel i rarely put ads on
my youtube videos
um recently i haven't at all let me show
you why so set up google adsense
there's errors here let's see what the
crack is fix in adsense
and i need to pop my details in
and i'm in boom so your ads
units are not displaying ads because you
haven't yet verified your
pin adsense no longer shows youtube
metrics verify your billing address now
here's the thing
this is the figure that we've all been
waiting for so in total
over the lifetime so the last seven days
i've earned nothing on youtube
this is youtube direct obviously this is
not like me just as a general person
uh yesterday nothing today nothing this
month nothing
the reason i'm earning nothing at the
moment is because there's a problem here
i haven't verified my pin however my pin
hasn't been verified since august 2019
so over a year i think what's happened
is
i've received a total
paycheck or a total amount i've earned 4
302 pounds 26 pence from youtube now
that amount that's hit my threshold
maybe that's five thousand dollars
and it's the youtube threshold um so i
haven't actually claimed any of that
money
so that money is all sitting in youtube
and until i
get my pin sorted and claim that money
it's i'm unable to run ads on my channel
so there we have it how much have i got
from youtube
four thousand three hundred and two
pounds and 26 pence
and until i've actually claimed my pin
and got that money
i'm not able to earn any more money from
youtube and you know what i'm not really
that bothered i'll probably at some
point
i'll get the pin and i'll get the money
in and i'll probably give that money to
my charity
or uh or or put it back into the
business
employ more videographers to continue
making more content maybe i'll put it
towards getting a drone or something can
up the quality of the footage so i
really don't make that much money from
youtube in fact
i haven't made any money officially from
youtube no money's hit my bank account
ever from youtube
my training company uh i don't take any
money from that at all as a salary
and right now the trading company's not
making any money and it hasn't for quite
a long time and even when
corona's finished and it's back up
running events i don't ever expect it to
be
to be particularly profitable i make my
money
from investing successfully in property
and i've been i started youtube just
vlogging my property journey
i started property 12 years ago and i
was well known
in the property world for being very
successful very
young people knew me people knew who i
was i became a millionaire
from packaging and selling deals
in property like that's how i became a
millionaire so
maybe i should stop running ads again on
my youtube channel uh maybe i should
claim the money in
uh maybe i should monetize things it's
funny because i i think i don't know
what it is exactly mate
i i i think i have a reputation maybe
because i talk about money a lot and i'm
an unashamed capitalist
uh and i'm loud and i am a compassionate
capitalist i do believe in helping
people and the people looking after the
people but
i think i have a reputation for being
someone who is
uh like a bit of a money money money
kind of person like i'll grab every
penny
and actually you know what i'm actually
not really like that at all in real life
uh i do things because i i do things
that i love to do
i'm a family man i do things that i love
to do of course for my business man
uh yes sometimes and this is another
thing because
because of my training sometimes people
will come to me and they get they're
shocked
because they'll say something i wonder
you're training and they'll literally be
wanting to pay for training
from my company and i'll say don't do it
i don't think you should do i don't
think i don't think it's right that you
do the training because i don't think
you're in a position where you can
actually take action i don't think
you're in there
but then other times if i think someone
needs to do it i'll be like
you've got to do this right you and my
passion comes through and then people
think oh my gosh samuel leeds is this
big sales person that's like money
grabbing
uh i'm not motivated by money i'm not
meaning to be braggy or anything now but
when when you
become pretty successful like last year
just alone i made millions of pounds
last year profit
it doesn't become about the money
anymore john maxwell says that once
you've
tasted significance success loses its
taste and for me
genuinely i do what i do from a position
of love you know i wouldn't be motivated
to do a youtube video every single day
all through the pandemic when i'm not
even able to run training events
not claiming not claiming batman i
wouldn't be able to do that
if i was trying to do it for the money
when i'm not making money from doing it
anyway
like the reason i do youtube is is
because i love
getting the message out there the reason
that i turned ads on for a little bit
back in the day
was because i was told by some other
youtubers
that when you put ads on your channel
youtube like it and then youtube
show more people your video and my whole
mission is about as many people
seeing my content as possible because i
want to change lives i want to see
leave a legacy as cheesy as it sounds i
want to be part of people's stories
that's what gets me going when when i
get every single week i've got someone
coming on my youtube channel saying
samuel you know your your message your
training your teachings has actually
changed my life it changed my finances
that gives me a kick winners on a
wednesday every single week it's good
content as well
um that's really what makes me drive so
i'm sure at some point i'll get my pin
thank you youtube i do love your youtube
just because i don't get the money off
you i'll pull about four thousand pounds
and i'll i'll buy a drone and i'll buy
some equipment with it no doubt
um and yeah if you think i'm silly if
you think i should start monetizing my
channel properly
uh and getting sponsors you you'll never
see you i've never done a sponsor i've
just done
my very very first um
kind of sponsor i just got a you'll
probably see it coming soon i just got a
really nice big hot tub in my garden
and they said can you give me a shout
out on youtube i was like yeah sure i
will they said i will also give you a
thousand pound discount now the hot
tub's like
almost thirty thousand pounds it's a
small discount i i was like
oh okay well i would have done it anyway
because when you see me shouting people
out
when you see me talking about mortgage
brokers and i'm not getting commission
from that like when you see winners on a
wednesdays like
it's just genuine people that i want on
my channel so
again maybe i was silly maybe i should
start being more
clever about the monetization of it i
know
and you know maybe i am a businessman
100
i like to make money 100 but for me
youtube is a mission it's a passion it's
a hobby
and indirectly do i get paid from doing
youtube yeah for sure you know what
i'm doing joint ventures with people all
the time off the back of my training
company
which is off the back of my social media
i'm doing i'm getting people contacting
me all the time with property deals and
leads and oh my god you know
my gran has passed away and been
inherited this big piece of land and i
could potentially get planning
and i'm like okay maybe we could do
something and it comes from people
knowing who i am so
you know sure there are big massive
benefits to me
from people knowing who i am but this is
a mission this is a passion
uh if you think i should start
monetizing my channel better then
comment below if you've got suggestions
let me know if you think i should turn
on ads let me know
and hopefully you found this video
enlightening
and i only did this video because so
many people were asking me
how much i get paid from youtube now you
know
comment below subscribe smash the like
button because honestly
i spend so much time i put so much
effort into youtube
and i can put that effort into doing
lots of other things but i do it because
i want to serve people i want to help
people
uh and i want to see people win so
please do me a favor and subscribe
and turn the bell on and smash the like
button
drop a comment i'll see you next time
peace out